hello everyone
greetings from london first of all i
would like to thank pi data for giving
me
the opportunity to present here today i
would also like to thank all the
volunteers at numfocus
for organizing this meetup so let's get
started
when you work in the field of data
you're typically dealing with
various data sets from diverse sources
and then you face the problem of
integrating the data sets across
multiple sources
so with my talk here on advanced entity
matching at scale
i discuss some of the techniques to
identify and link the records
corresponding to the same entity
across one or more or various sources
and how to do it in a scalable way
so before we get started a little bit
about myself
i am laurenti almeida and i'm a data
scientist at
wholesale banking advanced analytics
department at ing bank in london
so we are a very diverse team of around
120 people
from various backgrounds and many
different nationalities
we have data scientists data engineers
product owners
business development owners software
developers and uxers in our team
if you're keen on joining us please
reach out
so here's the outline for my talk today
first i'll discuss the problem statement
and explain why we need entity matching
at scale
and next i'll go into candidate
selection which is basically a set of
techniques
to select the relevant candidate pairs
and then i'll discuss name clustering
which is a way to enhance the ground
truth data
and finally i'll conclude with our
learnings and outlook
so introduction ing is a global
bank with more than 35 million customers
in over 40 different countries and at
ing we deal with retail clients such as
you and me
and with corporate clients or businesses
so at wholesale banking we focus on
corporates and ing naturally has a data
consolidation problem
to consolidate the data across various
internal and external data sources
and it's important for ing to get the
holistic view of entities
so there are few primary use cases for
us to implement
entity matching and the first one is to
match external bank accounts to ing
accounts and for this we look at names
and transactions
we also want to match high risk names to
international watch lists
and this is to either detect or to
prevent fraud or anti-money laundering
but it's not as straightforward it's
just matching names across different
data sets
because different names are used to
refer to the same entity
and in our ground truth data we
typically have only one name that's
present
so we already i have a name matching
algorithm but the current recall is very
low or it's only 55.6 percent
so in this talk i'll discuss two
techniques to improve the recall
of the current name matching algorithm
so as i said i'll focus on one of the
use cases today
where we try to match names in millions
of transactions to non-entities
or the entities which are already
registered with ing and for that we look
at names in the transactions
so some of the definitions before i go
further and the first one
is ground truth so it's basically the
internal data set
that we match the incoming data sets to
and then those external data set or
names to match set
which we are trying to match to the
ground truth data
so now why do we need data matching or
entity matching at scale
so just to give an idea of the kind of
data that we are dealing with and the
scale of data
in the ground truth we have around 13
million records and in our transaction
our external names to set names to match
set
we have around 3 million transactions
so we have ing present in a lot of
countries and because of which
we have a lot of special characters and
exotic characters which are present
in the names in our transaction data and
also in our internal ground truth data
so in our ground truth we have around
330 distinct characters which are
present
and in our names to match or external
transaction data
we have around 366 distinct characters
which are present
now if you look at the name matching
problem here so we are
typically trying to match around 3
million to 5 million records at a time
to the ground through data which has
around 13 million records
now that would make it a quadratic
problem because it would make
around 39 trillion record pair
comparisons
so we have a very big cluster at ing but
even with the size of the cluster that
we have
asking for asking to do 39 trillion
record pair comparisons is
still quite a lot
and we also have different ways in which
the entities are referred by to give an
example if you look at image on the
right
the first block shows the set of ground
root name and the second block shows the
set of external names
so in ground truth we have mr clean
unilever and png
and in our external data set or names to
match we have names starting with mr
clean
name starting with monsieur proper and
name starting with don limpio
so these are the set of names associated
with the same entity
but because of its presence in different
countries it is
referred by different names in different
countries now when we try to match all
the set of names associated with this
entity to the ground truth
we would only be able to match the first
two names because it's similar to the
name in the ground truth
but we would still have mismatches for
the name starting with don limpio
even though it is actu it is actually a
relevant candidate pair
and this is just one way in which the
names are referred or the names are
represented
so sometimes we have people using
company names or honor names to refer to
an entity
sometimes they would use abbreviations
or a very generic name to refer to the
same entity
and as shown in the example if an entity
is present in different countries they
are represented in different ways
sorry and if we have different
companies under the same entity then
sometimes people would refer to that
entity
by the company name and sometimes they
would refer to that
entity by using the subsidiary name of
the company
so as i said when we try to match all
the names associated with
an entity to the ground truth data then
we would have a lot of mismatches so
this is one of the reasons why we have a
low recall at the moment
and also realistically when you think
about matching
names in the external set to 13 million
names in ground truth the number of
realistic fakes is also quite high
which is another reason for the low
recall so currently our focus is on
improving the recall
so this is a typical entity matching
process when you have two data sets that
you want to match with each other
the first step is cleaning and
standardizing the data
and the next step is indexing where you
select the relevant candidate pairs
and once you have that then you
basically do the record pair comparisons
for the relevant candidate pairs
and finally you have the supervised
layer where you classify the record
pairs as matches
non-matches and possible matches once
that's done
then you have the evaluation stage or
manual review of the
record pairs which are classified into
different categories
i've taken this image from peter
kristin's research paper on
indexing techniques for scalable record
linkage and deduplication
he has done a lot of research in the
field of record linkage
so in my talk today i'll focus on
indexing and record pair comparison
so one key thing to note here is that
as i said we are focused on improving
the recall so if
indexing fails it will not catch or it
will not find the relevant candidate
pairs
but if indexing works and it is able to
find all the relevant candidate pairs
the precision might be low but we don't
have to worry about that at the moment
because the supervised layer is pretty
good at detecting the correct and
incorrect name pairs and the irrelevant
candidate pairs can later be filtered
out in the supervised layer
so i'll start with candidate selection
now why do we need indexing so the main
one of the main reasons why we need
indexing is to reduce the computational
complexity
so if you take my previous example of
matching 3 million records to
13 million records in our ground truth
data it will generate
39 billion 39 trillion record pair
comparisons
but as i said a bulk of those name pairs
are irrelevant
or it's very easy to filter out obvious
mismatches from that
so the idea of indexing is to first
filter out obvious mismatches from the
data
and to move similar records close
together so that
further down in the line of further down
in the entity matching process
you have very few record comparisons to
make
so this is the current uh pipeline that
we have for
name matching algorithm so we have two
sets of records
two sets of names that we want to match
with each other
so first we talk nice the names in both
the data sets
using n-grams or word grams and then we
convert that into vectors
using term frequency inverse document
frequency matrix
and then we compute cosine similarity on
the term frequency inverse document
frequency matrices so it is important to
note here
that this is not a typical nlp pipeline
where we are trying to
find it semantic information from the
data so we have two sets of names
and other information related with that
entity
so all we are trying to do is to
identify the sub strings or subgrams
that is present in both set of names and
to do a
similarity computation on top of that so
at ing we have already developed a
package called sparse.top in
which computes the cosine similarity on
large data sets in a very efficient
manner
but it still has the problem that it is
of quadratic complexity or that it
basically goes through
all the records in both the data sets
and does
many record pair comparisons so we are
trying to reduce that
by ensuring that we get a high recall or
recall good enough
added on top of this candidate selection
technique
so that's where so the neighborhood
indexing comes in
so it's a very simple and efficient
technique to create
candidate pairs or relevant candidate
pairs between two sets of names
so i'll briefly explain how sort of
neighborhood indexing is implemented
so we have two sets of names the one
which is shown in
red color and another set of names shown
in green color
so now in order to implement certain
neighborhood indexing
we create something similar to an
inverted index by combining the set of
names in both the sets
and sorting it in alphabetical order and
once it's sorted in alphabetical order
we fix a window link for sort
neighborhood indexing
and the window moves over the sorted
sorted
list and find candidate pairs within the
window
so it looks at names or name pairs
within the window
and if either of the names belong to
either data sets then it will create
name pairs between them
so it will go through the window
basically moves through the entire list
and the image on the right shows the
candidate base which is generated
for the names which i've shown so the
circles
in red show the names from the first
data set and the circles in green
show the names from the second data set
and the lines between the circles
or the notes show the candidate pairs
which are created between
different sets of names in both the data
sets
so sort of neighborhood indexing works
pretty well when both data sets have
similar size or similar length
and it is also particularly useful in
identifying candidate pairs with partial
matches
which cosine similarity is not really
good at
so to give an example let's say we have
a name pair where one of the names is
company name and another name is company
name
plus subsidy name so now when we try to
compute consent similarity between the
set of names
then it will give a very low question
similarity score because it's only a
partial match
whereas when we apply so the
neighborhood indexing since it's based
on sorting it will move this candidate
pairs close together
and now it will find this as a relevant
or flag it as a
relevant candidate pair
so how do we evaluate different
candidate selection techniques
the first one is using reduction ratio
so reduction ratio is the number of
candidate pairs which are generated
compared to all possible candidate pairs
the next one
is recall or pairs completeness it is
basically the non-true matches included
in the candidate
record pairs and the third one is
precision or pairs quality
it is the number of generated candidate
pairs which correspond to the correct
candidate pairs
so these are the three main metrics with
which we we compare the different
candidate selection techniques
and we also look at how long it takes to
compute each candidate selection
technique
so we applied sort of neighborhood
indexing on one of the open source data
sets
known as security exchange commission
data set with a list of companies
and on the x-axis we show recall and on
y-axis we are showing precision
and different dots represent the varying
length
of window of course sort of neighborhood
indexing technique
and as you can see from this plot
because in similarity
sorry sort of neighborhood indexing
enhanced with rotation of the tokens is
giving the best results with respect to
precision and recall
followed by enhancing the certain
neighborhood indexing with normal and
sorted tokens
so as you can see here we have applied a
different data
enhancements before applying so to
neighborhood indexing
and the main reason for this is because
as it said so the neighborhood indexing
is based on sorting
and it need not necessarily be that you
have all the
matches in the beginning of strings so
for example when you have
words which are swapped or when you have
matches towards end of the springs
the original sort of neighborhood
indexing may not catch that
so the idea is to enhance or apply this
different data enhancements
prior to applying sni and once you apply
sni when you combine all these different
data enhancements and then sni then it
will give
give pretty good boost in recall
so here's another comparison puts out
the neighborhood indexing
for a window length of 13 and applying
different data enhancements prior to
that
so if you look at the s and i baseline
it gave us a recall of around 44.08
percent
now there's another record which is
highlighted here that is reversing the
names and all we are doing there is
reversing the names in both the sets
now after applying sni after reversing
the names
it gave us a recall of 54.46 percent and
that's a huge boost
compared to the baseline sni because it
gave around 10
increase in recall so
one thing to note here is that depending
on the data that you're dealing with
when you do certain enhancements you get
pretty good boost in recall and since
sni itself doesn't take a lot of time to
compute
you can apply this data enhancements and
then do s and i
on top of it so to compare it with
cosine similarity
um computation so cosine similarity gave
us a recall of around fifty point nine
six percent
with a precision of five point five one
percent
and combining different data
enhancements and applying sni
on top of it gave us a recall of fifty
nine point zero four percent and a
precision of
one point zero four percent so here even
though the precision is very low for sni
we don't have to worry about it
because we know that or we have seen
that in the supervised layer
we are able to filter out the incorrect
matches
pretty easy pretty easily and
combining the multiple data enhancements
with sni
gave us a boost in recall of around
eight percent which is
pretty good so here's another
comparison of the execution time for
different candidate selection techniques
so on x-axis we have different lengths
of ground truth data and on y-axis we
have the execution time
so the yellow curve shows the execution
time for
s and i with a window length of 13 and
the gray and
red curve show execution time for cosine
similarity word based
and in gram based and as you can see
s is scaling pretty well and for a
ground rule data of 3 million records
sn8 takes only 16 minutes compared to
more than two
two hours for question similarity in
gram-based technique
so sni is a very fast candidate
selection technique
compared to similarity in gram and word
based
so some of the key takeaways here
combining multiple candidate selection
techniques actually help improve the
recall
and sni is a very simple technique to
add recall
and one of the reasons why we need to
combine multiple candidate selection
techniques is because
different candidate selection techniques
help in identifying different kinds of
name pairs
and that's what gives the boost in
recall
and on testing it on security exchange
commission data set
we can see that we got a an improvement
in recall by around eight percent
and also uh sni is particularly useful
when you have the ground flow data which
is not too large
so now i'll discuss name clustering
which is a technique
to enhance the ground rule data
so why do we need name clustering as i
said our goal is to match all the names
associated with an entity to the name in
ground truth
this but as i showed before we typically
have only one name that's present in
ground rule data
so what we're proposing here is to apply
clustering on the set of unique names
associated with an entity
and pick the cluster seed names and add
that as an alternate name in the ground
truth so that in future when we do the
matches we have
a higher recall or we are able to do
more matches
so i'll explain that in a bit more
detail so
it's same as the previous example where
we have ground truth
uh mr clean unilever and png and in the
names to match set or the external set
we have names starting with mr clean
monster proper and name starting with
don limpio
now we know that all these names are
associated with the same entity
or are associated with mr clean but when
we try to match the set to ground truth
we would only get matches for mr clean
and the first two records of mr clean
because that's similar to the name in
ground truth
but we still want to able to match all
the records associated with it
so basically we would apply clustering
on the unique set of names
associated with an entity which is
basically all the names that i've shown
on names to math set
and then we would take the cluster seed
name so here the cluster seed names
would be mr clean
don limpio and mr proper for example
and if i add this plus the seed names to
the ground truth
and try to match it we would get more
matches
so that's what i'm trying to do here so
basically i add the don limpio as an
alternate ground truth name associated
with mr clean
and that helped me have more matches so
it basically mr clean matches with mr
clean and mr clean the first two records
and don olympia matched with all the
records starting with don lympio
and not that in ground truth don limp
you and mr clean
are associated with the same entity
so i'll briefly explain the clustering
algorithm so we take the set of unique
names associated with an entity
and sort them in the decreasing order
frequency of usage
if we have any names with the same
frequency we sort them alphabetically
now in order to form the clusters the
highest frequency name
form the seed of the first cluster now
we compare the second name
with respect to the first name with
respect to a threshold function
and if the second name passes the
threshold function with the first name
then it forms another name in the first
cluster if not it will form a seed of
the second cluster
and we repeat that until we go through
all the names associated with an entity
so here we would basically have it's
important to note that
each name would only belong to one
cluster and the basic requirement for us
here
is to have a highly efficient algorithm
and
also another thing to note here is that
the clustering algorithm that we have
implemented is quite similar to the
canopy clustering algorithm
that peter kristen has described in his
indexing techniques research paper
so currently we have a very simple and
fast algorithm to do clustering
and to separate out different sets of
names
in the external set and then add as an
alternate
ground root name so now how do we set
the threshold function
the threshold function is just a
criteria to separate out obvious
mismatches in the data
and in our case we basically look at
combination of concentrative word based
and in gram based
so here this is a plot of cosine
similarity values for positive name
pairs
and on x-axis we show cosine similar to
word-based and on y-axis we have
question similarity
three gram-based now since these are
positive name pairs
we would expect almost all the points to
be concentrated in the bottom right
corner
top right corner but as you can see we
still have records in the bottom left
corner
because why we expect them to be
concentrated on the top right is because
these are positive name pairs and almost
all the values of cosine similarities
should be on the higher range
so since we are seeing values in the
bottom left corner we know for a fact
that
these are obvious mismatches or these
are quite different
so if we take the example of mr proper
we would basically have mr proper with
mr proper
and mr proper so that particular name
pair
being on the top right corner and
mr clean and don limpio name pair being
on the
bottom left corner which clearly says
that they
can be separated out in the clustering
so we apply
a simple and very loose threshold
function based on this
basically the criteria saying that if a
particular
question similarity for a particular
name pair if the cosensum like the word
based and in gram-based values
are falling within this threshold then
you separate it out into different
candidate pairs and this is based upon
the data that we have
so depending on the data that you deal
with you can also use any threshold
function
that set the criteria for names to be
separated out into
two different clusters
so we apply clustering on security
exchange commission data set
and these are some of the examples of
clustering and as you can see in the
first example
cluster zero start with name starting
with alan test
and we have cluster one with names
starting with test edger
and as you can see um let's say
typically we only have allen test
as a ground truth name for this
particular entity
then we won't be able to match test
edgar whereas after applying clustering
we know that test edger
should be added should be added as an
alternate ground truth name
so in future we would be able to match
this and the same applies for
the other example of don limpio on the
right as well
so we would add don limpio mr proper
monsieur proper
as alternate groundhog name so that we
would be able to find more matches and
thus
boost recall so we basically applied
clustering on all the names associated
with all the entities in our external
set
and enhance the ground rule data with
respect to that
so here i'm basically comparing the
enhancement of ground truth techniques
based upon candidate selection
so as i said we typically have only one
name that's present in the ground road
and after applying cluster we pick the
cluster seed names
and add them as alternate ground truth
name
and apply candidate selection on top of
that so the plot that you see here on x
axis we have different ground root
specification and on y
axis we have the maximum recall so the
first set of bars
is the candidate selection with respect
to original ground truth
and the second set of names is a
candidate selection with respect to
ground truth that is enhanced with top
three frequent names
and the third set of names is the
candidate selection with respect to
ground truth enhanced with top three
cluster scene names
now if you look at for all the candidate
selection techniques
the ground truth enhanced with cluster
seed name is giving the best results
out of all three and also if you look at
the green bar which is combination of
all
three candidate selection techniques the
cluster scene the ground truth enhanced
with cluster seed name is over
performing other techniques
so basically some of the key takeaways
from this clustering is essential to do
proper entity matching and without
clustering we know that
if we try to match a set of external
entity names to the ground truth we will
have a lot of mismatches
and we won't be able to match all the
names associated with an entity
so currently we have a fast clustering
algorithm which is version 1.0 and it
works pretty well
and the time to run clustering on 1.8
million names is around 33 minutes
and it has increased the ground through
these are only by around 15 percent
so to conclude we noted that
combining multiple candidate selection
techniques is essential in improving
recall
and sni is a very simple and efficient
technique to improve the recall
because different candidate selection
techniques also catch different kinds of
name pairs it's important to combine
them
and we also have a very fast and simple
clustering algorithm that can improve
name matching
by adding alternate names to the ground
to data
so overall the recall increased from 68
percent to 82 percent
by applying clustering on the
combination of candidate selection
techniques
and the recall increased from 58 percent
to 82 percent
which is roughly around 24 percent by
enhancing the ground rule data by
applying clustering and also combining
multiple candidate selection techniques
so as you can see we were able to make a
good improvement in recall after
applying these techniques
and the precision would definitely go
below uh two percent or three percent in
this case
but we are not worried about precision
because we know that the supervised
layer is pretty good at
filtering out the incorrect name pairs
so i i mentioned the supervised layer a
lot
during the presentation and we are
currently working on a supervised layer
and
it's giving pretty good results and it
is able to increase the precision
while maintaining a high recall and
i think that's perhaps something to
discuss later so
yeah thank you that's it from my from me
thanks for listening